[Music]
do
one of the fundamental thesis of this
course is that
in in modern literature
and in literature that isn't so modern
there's the notion of a human created
monster
frankenstein right springs to mind and
at an adequate time i mean frankenstein
was a a fantasy an unconscious fantasy a
dream in actuality about the potential
dangers of unbridled technological
advancement right well this frankenstein
uh monsters face us daily i mean it's
become a constant part of our existence
why is that well maybe it's something
like this and this is certainly a a
notion that jung would agree with
if we don't develop
a moral sense as conscious and as
elaborated as our technological sense
the fact that we're
capable of becoming increasingly
powerful will necessarily do us in
right
the bigger your weapons the smarter you
better be to control them and so maybe
it is something like this maybe and this
is a strict union notion maybe 500 years
ago when we started to
ratchet up the rate at which we were
developing our technological expertise
and left our
mythological and religious
presuppositions and conceptions behind
as archaic and perhaps as predicated on
superstition maybe we need to spend as
much time updating them and bringing
them into the domain of clear
consciousness and control as we have
spent on developing our technological
sense
if you were a medieval christian or an
archaic religious thinker of any sort
your first presupposition was that the
world and the cosmos existed exactly as
they appeared which with you or at least
your village or town or country at the
center
and certainly with the earth at the
center and with the cosmos as a shield
around the earth and with the earth
itself
as the domain of man being the
fundamental attribute of the cosmos so
this is a quotation from jung
and it's one i like a lot
because i think it
adequately and succinctly describes the
distinction between
the way that modern people think and the
way that people think if they're still
ensconced within a traditional belief
form
how totally did the different did the
world appear to medieval man for him the
earth was eternally fixed and at rest in
the center of the universe
encircled by the course of a sun that
solicitously bestowed its warmth despite
the fact that pre-empirical people had
to deal with death and disease on a
scale that i think is completely unknown
to us
it doesn't seem unreasonable to
presuppose that there was a certain
degree of comfort to be found in a world
view of this sort right because it
appeared at least
to the casual observer that the cosmos
was
human-centric
and that the notion that human purpose
was in some way
associated with cosmic significance
seemed to be beyond question at least in
part because there were no theories of
reality that would compete with that
initial preconception
men were all children of god under the
loving care of the most high who
prepared them for eternal blessedness
and all knew exactly what they should do
and how they should conduct themselves
in order to rise from a corruptable
world
to an incorruptible and joyous existence
such a life no longer seems real to us
even in our dreams
natural science has long ago
torn this lovely veil to shreds
how is it that people could think that
way given that it was so wrong and still
survive
given that in large part we are
necessarily creatures of tradition how
is it that we can sever the ties with
the manner in which our ancestors
thought
and suffer no ill consequences in result
people think automatically and i think
for good reasons that
the march of human thought has been
unbroken progress towards increased
rationality increased power increased
clarity but it's certainly the case that
as a consequence of sacrifice of our
religious beliefs and our philosophical
beliefs
the problems of meaning have become more
paramount for the modern person and then
you might ask well what exactly are the
consequences of that and i think
initially
the best perspective to take is one
that's historical
as we've moved away
from a classical
mystical or mythological worldview
a number of dramatic occurrences have
unfolded
we've become much more technologically
powerful right the application of a
strict empirical model designed to
abstract out from everyone's experi
experience those things that are
material and constant have enabled us to
produce
technological implements
of extreme power right both for good at
least in principle with regards to
medical advances and also for ill in
terms of our ability to control
weapons of unbelievable destructive
force
so we're more powerful are we any
smarter or any wiser
well i think a casual glance at the
history of the 20th century would
suggest that perhaps we're not i don't
think there's any indication whatsoever
although perhaps things have improved in
the last 15 years
that
an additional consequence of our
capacity to extract ourselves from our
religious modes of thought has been a
palpable increase in wisdom or tolerance
or compassion
or a palpable increase in our ability to
understand explicitly what might
constitute the basis for a suitable and
stable state
so you might take for example the fact
that the 20th century has been
unbelievably bloody
right literally hundreds of millions of
people killed in conflicts of one form
or another both external say in the
course of world war ii or vietnam and
internal in the case of nazi germany or
the soviet union or any of the vast
array of countries who've
subjected their citizens to terrible
internal repression in the name of the
maintenance of order
alexander solzhenitsyn estimated that 60
million people died in the soviet union
between 1919 and 1959
as a consequence of internal repression
and his estimates were that perhaps
twice that many died during the cultural
revolution in china
looking back on the 20th century one
scene one thing seems relatively clear
right
although
humanity as a whole has ceased or had
ceased at least to engage in large-scale
religious conflicts although they seem
to have been making a vicious comeback
in the last five years
our ability to live together still seems
incredibly compromised
by our capacity to engage in ideological
conflict
right and it doesn't seem to me
ridiculous to presume
that the battles between capitalism and
communism say or between capitalism
communism and fascism or even the
emergent struggle between fundamentalist
islam and the west
can necessarily be regarded as anything
but extensions of our tendency towards
religious and mythological conflict even
though in principle systems like
communism and fascism were not
predicated on explicitly religious
presuppositions
well it seems to me that a logical
conclusion
from observations of that sort is that
even if you eradicate the traditional
trappings of the mythological worldview
which seems to be what's happened as a
consequence of our rise in empirical
knowledge that you don't eradicate the
tendency for people to formulate groups
belief systems
around conceptions of ways that you
should behave
that are at the very least religious in
structure in action even if they're not
religious in name i mean i think it's a
very peculiar
coincidence for example that
the soviet communists erected a male
trinity
marx
lenin and stalin as an apparent
replacement for the masculine trinity
that comprised the essential deities of
orthodox
russian orthodox christianity why would
these forms re-emerge so spontaneously
and what does it mean that people who
regard themselves as essentially modern
and empirical in their presuppositions
seem to be absolutely susceptible
in their fundament to ideological claims
well if you look at the soviet union
which i think is a very instructive case
because the soviets the russians
were really the last european power to
fall prey to
the conflict between empiricism and
science and religion and they didn't
really fall prey to that until the
mid-1800s because russia was a
relatively close society relatively
illiterate uh maintaining a medieval
structure far past
the time when other european countries
had abandoned that
in the 1850s a wave of atheism spread
across russia in some sense
as a wave of enlightenment but also as a
plague
and figures as
towering as tolstoy
remembered
in his memoirs the very day that he
realized that
the empirical discoveries of western
europeans had eradicated his ability to
believe in the russian orthodox system
you lose something like that what
happens well
if you believe that mythological
thinking is nothing but
superstitious empiricism and that it's
been replaced entirely by a more
appropriate modern view then nothing
happens right it's all to your benefit
to become enlightened but if you believe
that there's more to the story than that
and that more traditional ethical and
moral systems predicated on mythological
presuppositions offer you a map of how
to behave and what to think and how to
regulate your emotions and what to
strive for
none of which can be replaced by a
scientific perspective then the
eradication of a system like that leaves
a vacuum and then the question is what
rush is in to fill a vacuum well if you
look at the case of the soviet union it
seems quite instructive doesn't it i
mean there's a 30-year period where
there's tremendous intellectual clash
say between
a materialist and empirical perspective
and in a russian orthodox perspective
the russian orthodox perspective loses
its attractiveness for the reigning
intellectual elite and the
presuppositions of communism which
appear rational by contrast but which by
all evidence were not rush in to fill
the gap
and i want to read you something that
nietzsche wrote
it's perhaps the most famous thing he
ever said although it's almost entirely
taken out of context and misquoted and
if not misquoted at least misunderstood
because nietzsche was one of these
strange people who was capable of living
50 or even 100 years into the future and
although he was
is generally regarded as an enemy of
christianity and superstition and was
certainly an unbelievably outspoken
opponent of christian traditionalism he
also knew that if you let the old gods
die the probability that blood would
flood the land was virtually 100
so let me read you what he wrote
have you not heard
of that madman
who lit a lantern in the bright morning
hours ran to the marketplace and cried
incessantly
i seek god
as many of those who do not believe in
god were standing around just then he
provoked much much laughter
why
did he get lost said one did he lose his
way like a child said another or is he
hiding is he afraid of us has he gone on
a voyage or immigrated
thus they yelled and laughed
the madman jumped into their midst and
pierced them with his glances
wither is god he cried i shall tell you
we have killed him you and i
all of us are as murderers
but how have we done this
how are we able to drink up the sea
who gave us the sponge to wipe away the
entire horizon
what did we do when we unchained this
earth from its sun
whither is it moving now
whether are we moving now
away from all suns
are we not plunging continuously
backwards
sideward forward in all directions
is there any up or down left
are we not straying as though through an
infinite nothing do we not feel the
breath of empty space
has it not become colder
is not night and more night coming on
all the while
must not lanterns be lit in the morning
do we not hear anything yet of the noise
of the gravediggers who are burying god
do we not smell anything yet of god's
decomposition
gods to decompose
god is dead god remains dead and we have
killed him
how shall we the murderer of all
murderers
comfort ourselves what was holiest and
most powerful of all that the world has
yet owned has bled to death under our
knives who will wipe this blood off us
what water is there for us to clean
ourselves what festivals of atonement
what sacred games shall we have to
invent is not the greatness of this deed
too great for us
must we not ourselves become god simply
to seem worthy of it
[Music]
well as you can tell
it's a much different notion from the
casual god is dead quotation that's most
generally associated with nietzsche well
what is he saying he's saying something
like this
a system like christianity or any system
that's
con that's oriented to society for
thousands and thousands of years
can't simply be eradicated by a casual
gesture without consequences ensuing in
its aftermath
what consequences
well nietzsche says
well we'll no longer know up from down
what does he mean by that
metaphorically
well up that's where you're headed right
and down that's what you want to stay
away from and when you eradicate the
most fundamental presuppositions of your
system of values then there is no up and
there is no down and then where are you
precisely
well it's not so easy
it's not so easy to say having not
necessarily ever been in that position
what is your life like when you don't
know up from down is it merely neutral
is is there merely no value left or
could it possibly be the case that if up
and down have both been eradicated that
the place that you're left in is
something much more akin to a permanent
state of suffering because maybe it's
only the case that
the constant capacity to strive for up
in it being an up that you believe in
the constant striving for up is actually
what makes your life bearable to you and
if you lost the sense of up and down the
place that you would end up would be not
so much neutral as terrible
now if you have any belief system at all
you do this so let's say you're an
advocate of left-wing politics you take
a pro-environmental stance or an
anti-corporate stance which is a
relatively common thing to do among
undergraduates what do you do when you
hold that belief system
you view the world as it lays itself out
and you explain the manner in which it
manifests itself in terms of the axioms
of that belief system and you may know
that you can do it right you can tell a
credible story about why the world is
the way it is by adopting say an
anti-corporate perspective because there
are all sorts of terrible things about
the world that are a consequence say of
corporate maneuvering
and you might also say that and piaget
would say this that it's a necessary
developmental stage
to acquire allegiance to a given belief
system why
well any up is better than none that
might be the first observation so even
if your belief system is relatively
insufficient and easily challenged on
intellectual grounds and perhaps not
very complete anyways the fact that it
does lay out a moral structure for you
and tell you good from evil and right
from wrong
that's a that's a plus that's an
advantage now it's relative intellectual
weakness and it's incoherence assuming
it is incoherent to some degree that's a
flaw
but that doesn't mean that the effort to
establish a system like that is
worthless it's worthwhile and nietzsche
said say with regards to christianity
and europe
he said
well the errors intellectual and moral
of institutional christianity are
essentially beyond count
but
there's one thing you have to remember
first of all an ordering of that sort is
necessary
because the alternative
which is always hidden from you insofar
as you're inside a moral system the
alternative is far worse chaos that's
worse
[Music]
i mean part of the reason that the
germans preferred hitler
to chaos
was because they felt
that the order that hitler promised
repressive as it was was preferable to
the chaos that was likely to ensue in
its absence
what is it about chaos that's so
terrifying
second nietzsche said
adopting a belief system of any sort
and imposing coherency on the world
viewing it through the lens of that
explicit system
disciplines your mind
so for example
to live in the absence of any stated
beliefs is hardly to live at all to live
in the presence of a narrow minded
extreme belief system is at least to
undergo the rigors both behavioral and
intellectual of coming to terms with the
world from some perspective
nietzsche said the reason that the
modern mind
such as it is
was able to free itself from the past at
all
was because it had first
thoroughly subjected itself to the
tyranny that was imposed by the past
in consequence disciplined itself
developed enough discipline as a
consequence of that subordination to
then break free of it
in all science of morals so far one
thing was lacking strange as it may
sound the problem of morality itself
what was lacking was any suspicion that
there was something problematic here
every society every functioning
individual every functioning family
every social unit
has a moral code
but they differ
so what does that mean exactly well it's
complicated isn't it because the fact of
the universality of the code
the fact of the code indicates that the
code or our code is necessary
by the same token the fact that there's
a multiplicity of codes seems to suggest
that the particulars of a given code
aren't necessarily relevant and so
nietzsche says brilliantly i think we're
faced with a problem
no life without morality no absolute
morality
what do we do now one of the things jung
observed was that if you look at the
structure of stories he thought first
there's a relationship between stories
and moral codes well seems relatively
straightforward doesn't it if you tell a
simple story like a parable sometimes
they're complex too like an aesop's
fable say
what do you extract out from the story
a moral what's the moral what's the
implication of the story for behavior
right
so you tell a little story about someone
who acts out a given moral code and that
person does better or worse and the
moral the story is if you act in this
manner you will do better or worse
proverbial knowledge
we all tell
stories they have identifiable structure
you can tell that because a movie studio
in hollywood can produce a movie and
people all over the world will watch it
people all over the world all over the
world tell stories to one another
the plot elements seem similar
are the morals similar
that's a more difficult question
right we know that the details of
morality can vary from culture to
culture
is there anything that doesn't vary from
culture to culture now why would you
want to find that
well alexander solzhenitsyn thought that
one of the most
important occurrences of the 20th
century
who were the nuremberg trials
right the nurburg trials brought the
perpetu
perpetrators of the nazi genocide to
justice and it's easy to be cynical
about that and perhaps you should be
cynical about it because
the victors brought the losers to trial
and so of course
the losers were going to be tried from
the perspective of the winner's moral
code but solzhenitsyn says well wait you
know there's something more to this
story at least there seems to be in that
many of the events that characterized
the nazi atrocities were so
awful
outside of intellectual
argumentation because you can provide an
intellectual argument for anything they
were so awful
that the proper visceral embodied
response of any observer regardless of
specific moral code should be repugnance
period
such that
encoded at least initially in
international law
genocide is a crime against humanity
right no matter what the particulars of
your moral code
so goes the logic
you cannot construct a viable moral code
that enables genocide
if not a logical impossibility and i
think it is a logical impossibility it's
an ethical impossibility and then you
have to ask yourself
and this is not precisely an
intellectual question
does that seem credible to you
does it seem credible that there are
acts
that are so terrible
that no one regardless of their stated
position should ever engage in them and
if the answer is yes then i would say
well if you haven't moved towards
personal accept of acceptance of an
ultimate up
so to speak you've certainly identified
at least one down that you don't want to
approach
and that's the beginnings of the
establishment of some notion of absolute
moral authority
so what if we said hypothetically
something like this
let's say that
morality isn't a philosophy it's not
something explicit something implicit
how does it evolve well
emotional creatures produce it and you
don't have to produce it in isolation if
you were weren't a social animal if you
lived to solitary in nocturnal existence
by yourself there's no need for morality
because you don't have to regulate your
behavior with regards to your peers but
you're social animals so you're stuck
with everybody else but everybody else
could be conceived of as a grand average
right how would you act towards the
average person well i would say that
very very stable moral systems tell you
exactly that and they say things like
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you right basic principle of
reciprocity why does that work
and it's a complex precept it means i
should treat you like i would like to be
treated by you
and you might think well that means to
be nice to you but that isn't really
what it means because nice isn't enough
right what i want from you really
is communication real communication
feedback what am i doing that's
acceptable and good what am i doing
that's unacceptable and not good
and that latter
aspect of feedback is part of the reason
why if you're psychopathological and
isolated you're in much worse shape
because
half of your sanity or three-quarters of
it or 90 of it who knows is distributed
sanity you don't have to be that sane as
long as you're hanging around other
people because as soon as you do
something that's deviant they're going
to raise an eyebrow at you right and
then you think oh well
not that and as soon as you do something
good then they're going to pay more
attention to you and smile at you so all
of the information about how to regulate
yourself is out there
in the world right the average person
how many people do you interact with in
a week
300 say maybe it's not that many a
hundred
how about in a year
thousand two thousand five thousand
ten thousand
what are they all telling you
well the message is similar across
people how similar
don't know exactly how similar that's
what stories tell you